(audience cheers and applauds)
- [Kelly] Oh my God, I am
in love with your suit.
That's my favorite color.
- Yes, yes. Green's your favorite color?
- [Kelly] Yes. Yes.
- Oh, mine's red and blue.
- [Kelly] It is?
- Yes.
- It's very American of you.
- Yes. Thank you.
- Red and blue.
- Go USA.
- Yeah.
I used to love you until you
said Cowboys were gonna win.
And then look what happened.
I don't understand.
Everybody was saying that we were gonna,
look, we say it every year.
I get it, but like,
but I really did think, like,
we had all the players.
It was all there.
- I know. I did that
pick for you, too, Kelly.
- [Kelly] I, you, look-
- Yes.
- Here's the thing. I yelled so hardcore.
I became that crazy fan. Watch.
I got really into football this season.
I'm like into fantasy football.
Do you, have you ever
played fantasy, as well?
- I've never played fantasy football ever.
- Really?
- Mm mm. I know all
about fantasy football.
- But you don't think about that?
Like, as a football
player, you're like, man,
what if these people were
all combined on one team?
Well, you kind of had that 'cause, yeah.
(audience laughs)
- I actually knew how it worked.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And like throughout the
season when I was playing,
I always made sure I was like, okay,
if I can score a touchdown,
there's like two minutes
left in the fourth quarter.
We're already winning by
like three touchdowns.
But if I can somehow sneak
another touchdown in-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- For my fantasy owners,
they're gonna love me.
- That's what we say at home.
Just walking in and then
you start getting angry
at the other players that you don't have.
But it's so fun.
Anyway, does it anger you
that fans, we use the word we?
Like, we're like, we lost and,
like, we didn't do anything.
Like does it, you know what I'm saying?
- Actually, no. It
doesn't anger me at all.
Because without the fans,
we wouldn't have the NFL.
We wouldn't have the game.
- [Kelly] Well, that's good. Good answer.
- So, it's a collective.
- Good answer.
- So, we makes sense.
- Okay because I feel
insane at the end of that.
My daughter's like, "Why
do you keep saying we?"
And I'm like, "I used to be you. I know."
But now I'm them.
Anyway, what's like one of your favorite,
'cause you have so many
great Super Bowl moments,
like, what's one of your favorites?
- My favorite Super Bowl
moment is when I won
my first Super Bowl.
I got into the Super Bowl Club.
That's what it's all about.
- [Kelly] So cool.
- You just wanna get into that club.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And we beat the
Seattle Seahawks in 2015.
They were going to be a,
they were trying to be repeat champions-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Which hasn't been
done in quite some time.
It might be done this year
for the first time since
the Patriots did it what?
'03, '04?
But that game that we
played was just spectacular.
- Not Patriots, you mean Chiefs, right?
Or no, Patriot?
- Yeah.
No, no, the Patriots were the
last one to go back to back.
I think it was '03, '04.
- [Kelly] Oh, I thought you
meant who's going this year.
I was like, they're not going.
- And if the Chiefs win this year again,
they're the first team to go
back to back in Super Bowl wins
since the Patriots, I think '03, '04.
- Yeah.
- Right around those years.
But that Super Bowl versus Seattle,
Malcolm Butler with that game stealing-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Interception to win the game.
Let me tell you, it was
the most fabulous game
of all time and one of the
best Super Bowls ever, too.
- That's the thing about football.
You never know.
- [Rob] Yes.
- Yeah.
- That's why there's a movie
called "Any Given Sunday."
- [Kelly] I love that soundtrack.
- Yes.
- Oh, Missy Elliott has
a good song on that.
Of course, I went musical
with it. Whatever.
So wait, so Super Bowl's in
Vegas. I'm gonna be there.
You're gonna be there, obviously.
So like, are you excited?
Are you a Vegas guy?
- I'm a Vegas guy in a way.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And I look at Vegas totally different
than the way I looked at Vegas-
- [Kelly] Amen.
- When I was 22 years old-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- 23 years old.
- You remember it now.
- Yes, I didn't remember
it really back then.
- Yeah.
- When I was that age.
But Vegas I used to just think
was a complete party 24, 7.
You have to go there-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You're drinking right
when you get off the plane.
- You're drinking-
- [Kelly] Oh, the most sick
I've ever been in my life.
- Back on the plane when you're leaving
and you're thinking all about
what you just did the last 24 hours
or 48 hours you were there.
- Trying to recall it.
- Yeah. Recall it.
But I don't look at
Vegas like that anymore.
You know, I'm a little bit more older.
I like to go there now.
I like to go to shows.
- Yeah.
- I like to go to concerts.
I just like to enjoy the whole atmosphere
of what Vegas has to offer
and not just go there
and just start raging right away.
- Yeah.
Those are for 20 year
olds that have the ability
to wake up the next day
and not feel like death.
- [Rob] Yes.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, those 20-year-old days.
- Except I think we did
feel like death afterwards.
We just kept going back.
It's like pregnancy.
Why? Wait, why do we do it again?
I don't know.
I have to say it has to be
very different from, obviously,
playing the actual game
to then being an analyst.
Like, becoming that
and like talking about,
like, was that hard?
- A little bit because, you know,
I love to be put on the
spot, and fourth and goal,
you know, on the five yard line,
I'm used to that situation.
I love that situation
when my number's called
and I have to go up and make a play-
- Under pressure.
- But now I was using my body
and my mind in a physical way,
and now I'm doing it
more in a mental way, so-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So, we're on every
Sunday before the games.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And now, it's like fourth and goal,
but I'm doing it mentally.
- Yeah.
- And I gotta produce
live right on that spot
right at the moment.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Mentally, not physically anymore.
So it's a little bit of a
different transformation.
But I love it because I get
to offer my unique perspective
to the game of football, as well.
- [Kelly] We love it
as fans, watching you-
- And it's just so much fun doing it.
- Yeah. I said we again, whatever.
That does work, we.
Athletes do many of the same
things when they retire.
Gronk and his former
teammate, Julian Edelman,
recently had some fun with that.
So, let's see it.
- We're retired athletes.
We're gonna get jobs on TV.
We're gonna tease a comeback.
- We're retired athletes.
We're gonna watch our old highlights.
We're gonna start a podcast.
(audience cheers and applauds)
- This should have been an
SNL skit. It's so funny.
They should do that
with musicians, as well.
- We're retired athletes.
We'll go on "The Kelly Clarkson Show."
- There you go. Got it.
Good times. Good times.
So wait, whose idea was that?
Are you into social media?
- [Rob] A little bit.
- Okay.
- Yeah, social media's cool, you know.
You gotta use it for the right reasons.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But I was at Julian Edelman's house.
He has a great podcast
called "Names with Games."
- Yeah.
- And we just did his podcast
and he has his whole
social media team there.
And then they showed me
this new trend on TikTok
and that was the new trend.
And they were like, we're gonna
do it as retired athletes.
And it was such a great idea.
- [Kelly] So funny.
- And it came out so good.
- I know. I was telling you on the break.
I was like, that should have been on SNL.
That would've been a
really funny skit, yeah.
So, you have a new partner for
big game parties. Who is it?
- Yes, I actually do.
And Julian Edelman is now
a part of it, as well.
And this is my second year
teaming up with Bounty.
And that's why I'm in my green suit
because I am the Bounty man.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yes.
- And green is a great color.
- And I'm from Buffalo,
so I know a thing or two
about Buffalo, you know,
wings, as well.
- Yeah.
- And you gotta always have blue cheese
on the side when you're from Buffalo,
and you can't have football without wings,
and you can't have wings without Bounty.
- Okay. I can't have-
- It gets saucy. It gets messy.
The quicker pick upper
upper just comes and goes-
- [Kelly] I got you.
- Cleans you right up
- Quicker picker upper.
I remember that.
No, I agree with all of that,
except not the blue cheese.
I have to have ranch.
(audience cheers)
- When you're from Buffalo-
- I'm Texan.
- When you're from Buffalo,
you use blue cheese only.
- When you're Texan, you put
ranch or ketchup on everything.
- Yes, but when you're from Buffalo,
you gotta have the Buffalo blue cheese.
- Okay.
- But if you're outside of Buffalo-
- I won't make the argument.
Yes, you can have ranch-
- [Kelly] Just saying.
- 'Cause the Buffalo blue cheese
is the only legit blue cheese out there.
- Yeah. I like blue cheese.
I like blue cheese, but there's
something mm about ranch
that I really love.
- Nope. Blue cheese.
- Really, I just want the ranch.
- You gotta go to Buffalo.
- And I just wanna, I need something,
the vessel for it to get-
- Wait until you have
the Buffalo blue cheese.
- Okay. I have had Buffalo blue.
I like it. I like it.
And maybe when I'm-
- Where'd you go?
- In Buffalo, I'll do that.
- Yes, when you're in Buffalo.
- Everywhere else, I say no.
So, if you weren't an athlete,
and people ask me this about music,
but if you weren't an athlete,
what do you think you'd be doing?
- What would I be doing?
Well, my dad, he's been
in the fitness industry
for 33 years now, selling
fitness equipment.
A couple of my brothers
sell the fitness equipment
for him, as well, so I
love to workout still.
- Does your whole family
look this athletic?
You're just all? Okay.
- Yes, they all do. Yes.
- So does mine.
- They stay fit, and actually,
three of my brothers played in the NFL.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I played with two of
them on the Patriots
at a moment, too.
And then my fourth brother played
in the minor leagues
for baseball, as well.
So, we all made pros.
- Wow.
- And well, we all still work
out and we're all still active
and we all still compete
versus each other, as well.
- So how, oh my god.
So wait, there's four boys?
- Yes.
- Four boys growing up.
- There's four of us. Yep.
No, five of us total. My mom is an angel.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
I just prayed for her.
(audience applauds)
- [Rob] Yes, yes, yes. There we are.
- Oh my gosh.
I have one boy in my house, and it's nuts.
Y'all are very, well, you
break a lot of things.
So, how did your dad or mom settle fights?
How did, because that had to happen.
- Well, at first my mom would
try to settle the fights
and then she just let it go.
After about five months, she goes,
hey, I'm just gonna let them go.
They're gonna wear each other out.
- [Kelly] That's a good plan.
- And then we just had
a rule in the house,
no hitting in the face and
no hitting where it counts,
if you know what I'm talking about.
- Yeah, okay.
- So that was the only rules of the house.
Other than that, you can
beat down the other brother
as much as you want.
(audience laughs)
That's why I was so good at football.
I didn't feel those
hits because growing up,
since one years old, my
brother just pounding-
- Just been pounding.
- Pounding my quads.
- Oh yeah, 'cause you're not like high.
You're like fourth on the list,
right? Like, you're fourth.
- [Rob] Yes, I'm fourth.
- Yeah.
So you probably got beat up on.
- And I was the biggest
troublemaker by far.
- It's always, yeah. It's
always the smaller ones.
I heard you also played trumpet as a kid,
which I found random for some reason.
- Well, in fifth grade,
it was mandatory to play an instrument.
So, we had a trumpet and all
we did was hand-me-downs.
We handed me down sports equipment.
We handed me down clothes
in our family. I mean, hey.
- I just, the amount of saliva
that goes in that trumpet-
- The only way you can get by, hand me.
- Yeah.
- But I mean, they cleaned the trumpet.
- I'm a hand-me-down family. I get it.
- So, we would hand down
the trophy, not the trophy.
Well the, it is a trophy kind
of. The trumpet's a trophy.
And by the time it came to me,
there was 50 dents in the trophy
because it wasn't just used
for instrumental class,
it was also used as a
weapon in the house, yes.
- Your poor mother.
- We gotta get her on the show.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Having us, I mean.
- Write a book, ma'am. Okay.
Super Bowl predictions though.
Do you still, I heard on "The
Tonight Show," you said 49ers.
- They've been to the championship game.
- They haven't won-
- NFC Championship or Super Bowl, like,
literally the last five years,
and they can't get that
Super Bowl win, so-
- [Kelly] I know.
- I think this is the year for them,
even though it's gonna be
a tough game versus Chiefs.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I mean, they're playing
good right now, too.
- They are.
But man, I just, I think
I always go towards,
it's nothing against the Chiefs.
I always like an underdog story.
Like, the Lions was a
great story this season
until, you know, that last game.
But it was a great story.
Like it was like fun to
like go along with it.
- I agree, and I was actually
cheering for the Detroit Lions
to win it all, as well.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So I was sad when they lost.
- [Kelly] I know.
- Yeah.
- All right, let's do another quick break.
You can see Gronk attempt
FanDuel's Kick of Destiny
before the big game this Sunday.
Go online for details, everybody.